obviously we know you from little house
in the prairie
people assume that i am
laura ingalls wilder just as i played
her on the show and
yes deep down inside there is that
that little girl in me there is that
half pint that's still there
um that was there then
i craved that life i loved being on the
set i love being around the horses and
the chickens
melissa's got her own chickens now she
shares them with husband of almost 10
years 30-something star timothy busfield
at the rustic cabin in the catskills
it's a far cry from the first time we
met her on the set of little house in
1981. it was et's first year on the air
and melissa was dating rob lowe i'm just
a 17 year old girl who happens to be
working on a series and who happens to
be a celebrity i'm
just like everyone else
i have the same feelings
i blush a lot
what would you tell that 17 year old
teen well first thing i would tell her
is don't let them do that hairdo on you
again i don't know i sounded pretty
pretty good i mean it sounded like a 17
year old trying to find her way a little
dorky
but you know that's it's part of the job
i mean i get to see footage of myself
it's some very uh very very detailed
home movies i have between the
television series and then all the
interviews that went with it is there
any aspect of hollywood that you miss
i don't miss the pressure i don't miss
the race i don't miss the competition i
don't miss the feeling bad because i'm
not younger and thinner i do miss los
angeles i miss not the city itself i
miss my mom
and i miss my sister and my nephews and
i miss my kids who live there i don't
miss being in restaurants where the door
opens and everyone turns around to see
if someone bigger just walked in
now melissa's sharing her journey back
to the simple life in her second memoir
back to the prairie out now she says
being in lockdown inspired her to write
about what she learned during that time
of self-reflection in the book you write
life is full of traffic signals and i
was seeing a lot of red lights what kind
of red lights were you seeing stop
melissa you're not supposed to be dating
this guy was really what it was yeah
don't do this again i in my past had a
tendency to
not choose partners who had my best
interests at heart
that's a very generous way of saying bad
guys
also slipping back into the
the race of trying to stay young i mean
you know at 58 years old trying to be an
ingenue is just
not only is it futile it's frustrating
and it's a waste of time
this
should be celebrated women my age and
older should be able to say look what
you get to be right i earned my opinions
i am comfortable in my own skin
i love who i am at this age i love the
gray in my hair i
i um i welcome all the lines that yeah
there are days where i look in the
mirror and go oh she's the crypt keeper
the biggest thing i discovered
was that and this is a laura ingalls
wilder quote it's the sweet simple
things in life that really are the best
and most important i think i finally
reached a point and a place in my life
where
i
wanted and want and love having a
peaceful settled calm existence a lot of
the trauma and drama from my past is
gone and i've moved on from it i don't
have that
burning ambition that i used to have and
also my children are grown and gone so
i've got grandchildren now grandchildren
now eight grandchildren i have the
grandkids watch little house on the
prairie the oldest granddaughter
lulabelle is seven
and she did watch a little house in the
prairie she definitely wanted to have a
play date with me oh my gosh and she
asked her mom she called laura rolla she
couldn't say laura at the time she asked
her mom she could have a play date with
rolla
so she got to play date with granny mel
instead
[Music]